the history of our planet started over
four and a half billion years ago most
of this time there were all sorts of
diverse living organisms around
the earth's biosphere has come a long
way struggling for survival and its
history is marked with both periods of
vigorous evolution and disastrous
extinction events
in spite of all ordeals life has not
been wiped off the face of the earth
quite on the contrary it became a
separate factor capable of changing what
the planet is like today we invite you
to join us on a fantastic journey to the
past and see the most crucial milestones
in the paleontological history of our
earth as well as watch with our own eyes
the creatures that used to roam it
first we'll go as far back as the
archaean
the earliest prehistoric eon when living
organisms were around
we will find out what kind of creatures
lived on our planet in those mysterious
times
then we'll try to understand when and
why life left water so hospitable and
safe and ventured onto land
so forbidding and unwelcoming after that
we will see some of the most notable
creatures from the times of the
dinosaurs and also those who were to
succeed them
at the end of our journey we will take a
look at the most tragic moments in the
history of the biosphere on earth which
nearly left our planet a barren desert
let's get ready and we begin
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
giant monsters may have died out on
earth but talaria is still languishing
under their oppression in the new online
strategy game raid shadow legends you
will answer arbiter's call and defend
the world get your team together and
work out a foolproof strategy by
carefully selecting heroes according to
their special skills for example belinor
one of the high elves is pretty strong
in a one-to-one combat which makes him
indispensable in tackling the strong
bosses and del deskarg steals enemy
champions buffs so he will come in handy
in pvp battles
form alliances with other players to
beat the mighty bosses and get some cool
bonuses the game is continuously updated
and so new bosses are created and also
you can take part in events to acquire
new champs
in the latest update for example you get
to fight a new hydra rotation follow the
link in the description
and enjoy a great starting bonus the
epic hero tyrell and a whole set of
in-game boosters join the battle in raid
shadow legends
actually our earth has been not the
friendliest of places for the greater
part of its existence
let's cast our mind back to the archaean
eon
the earliest time when life was known to
be around
it began four billion years ago and
continued for approximately one and a
half billion years
the early earth had just gone through
the second heavy bombardment
several thousand tons of rocky debris
from the formation of the solar system
was hurled to the planet smashing the
thin basalt crust that had just formed
on the surface of moat and magma even
after this ordeal the young earth cooled
off again and gained its first
lithosphere
just a billion years later it became
home to the very first living organisms
the earth of that period had a
comparatively smooth surface
tectonic plates that is rocky bodies
that create high mountain ridges on
collision were simply non-existent at
that early time
there was no diversity in rocks on the
early earth either banks of wars and
rocks were in the first stages of
formation most of the earth's crust was
made up of basalt a rock formed from
magma and in essence it is solid lava
there was almost no oxygen in the
atmosphere in the archaean
the concentration of nitrogen was
considerably smaller than it is now
the earth was shrouded in a dense
mixture of water vapor and carbon
dioxide with a high percentage of oxides
of sulfur phosphorus and other active
chemical elements the sun was much
dimmer then than it is now according to
some estimates its luminosity was even
30 percent less than that of today
that is why our planet was quite a murky
place the moon still used to find itself
in close proximity to it so a day lasted
just around 10 hours
as for tidal waves they reached up from
several dozen to 300 meters
as the earth gradually cooled off water
in the atmosphere condensed and poured
down in torrential rains
at first it accumulated in small bodies
of water in lowlands this water was sour
salty and extremely hot up to a boiling
point in some places
its composition resembled that of
today's geezers
paradoxically this seemingly harsh
environment proved to be the cradle for
primitive life forms that originated and
evolved there
it goes without saying that first
organisms were anaerobic
instead of breathing oxygen as we do
which was non-existent in the atmosphere
at the time first living organisms
relied on other sources of energy
archaean organisms were not yet able to
swim in order to survive they needed a
substrate that is why the biosphere of
the time was a thin slimy film of not
more than a millimeter in width on the
bottom of a sour and hot ocean in its
coastal area
the maximal depth the biosphere reached
down was up to 20 meters as the dense
atmosphere did not allow sun rays to
penetrate deeper
the mouths of underwater volcanoes
offered habitats to bacteria that were
chemotrophs these bacteria didn't need
light and fed on other energy sources
relying on chemical reactions between
sulfur compounds and iron
the earth was cooling off sea levels
rose
the atmosphere became more rarefied and
the sun gradually grew in size
the coastal area favorable for life was
also gradually expanding and by the end
of the archaean eon the biosphere was
confined to a thin stripe along the
coasts and also oasis as it were on the
sea bottom near active volcanoes
meanwhile all the land rivers and most
of the open ocean were still completely
devoid of life
if an explorer were to visit the earth
of that period stromatolites would be
the only evidence of life seen with the
naked eye
these sedimentary limestone formations
were created by primordial
microorganisms and may reach up to
several meters in height
there was another problem in that age
the amounts of reagents were
insufficient and that greatly impeded
the evolution of life
evolution hadn't yet produced scavenges
organisms feeding on dead flesh
thus under the influence of gravity and
sea currents dead creatures accumulated
in cavities on the sea floor
hundreds of millions of years later
these accumulations were processed by
nature into what is now oil fields
around three and a half billion years
ago there are emerged creatures that
were to change the earth beyond
recognition
some bacteria got the hang of
photosynthesis involving oxygen
production
a billion years later on the border
between the archaean and the proterozoic
eons their revolution brought about the
most global extinction in the history of
the planet it is known as the oxygen
catastrophe to name but one term
i have spoken in more detail about it in
an earlier video it is hardly possible
to estimate the scale of that event as
an overwhelming majority of the
creatures didn't get preserved as
fossils practically all the diversity of
anaerobic life forms that had taken a
billion years to evolve
vanished off the face of the earth
the ancient earth's atmosphere was
exceptionally rich in methane as strong
greenhouse gas
it robustly oxidizes producing carbon
dioxide and water during the process
with methane's concentration in the
atmosphere dropping the temperature on
the planet decreased as well
as a result of this process there
occurred the huronian glaciation the
most large-scale ice age in the history
of the earth which started 2.4 billion
years ago and continued for as long as
300 million years
digging is revealed that in some areas
ice caps reached as far as the equator
with the planet almost totally
transformed into a ball of ice it took
the earth one and a half billion years
to go all the way from boasting boiling
lava fields to endless icy deserts
the proterozoic eon lasted from two and
a half billion years to
440 million years ago
life persevered in spite of the cold and
evolution although thwarted carried on
nevertheless land remained lifeless
living organisms concentrated in the
coastal area near the equator
and what was happening on the continents
even though they weren't crawling with
life yet land was experiencing something
different and interesting in its own way
alongside the continents banks of metal
oars and new rocks were being formed
in the proterozoic eon areas of dry land
alternately assumed different aspects
and were endless glaciers and stone
deserts at one time or another
it is hard to imagine but just a measly
500 million years ago the greater part
of our planet appeared quite like a
martian desert
luckily for all the dwellers of our
planet the sun was growing brighter and
warmer eventually the ice gave in
542 million years ago there began the
phanerozoic eon which is the greek for
the eon of visible life
it was peculiar for periods of active
evolution of different species
interlaced with mass extinctions
at the beginning of the paleozoic era
the greater part of land formed a giant
supercontinent named gondwana
located in the southern hemisphere it
had elaborate terrain and covered over a
hundred million square kilometers
it was comprised of today's africa south
america antarctica australia
the indian peninsula and some other
areas
the smaller continents of the day
lorentia baltica and siberia were
situated near the equator
apart from all that there was a great
number of smaller islands
still up until the silurian period which
started approximately
444 million years ago there weren't any
life forms to speak of on all these
expanses
only some simple mosses and lichens were
slowly establishing their dominance on
land it was only at the beginning of the
silurian period that first plants
emerged in tidal areas and near rivers
and only in the tropical zone of that
even in spite of the fact that sea
species and plants became more diverse
marine life forms still concentrated
near the coasts
the area populated incrementally
expanded
just to give you an example the depth of
the ocean at which photosynthesis was
able to take place in the devonian was
just 50 meters
which is 10 times as little as it is now
in the same period which began
420 million years ago and continued
until
358 million years ago the first
decomposers emerged organisms
decomposing dead flesh as a result their
emerged organisms feeding on products of
decomposition
for example alongside scavenging
bacteria there could be found sea
sponges at depths of up to 500 meters
the next period was the carboniferous
period it continued from 358 to 219
million years ago by the time it began
the greater part of the tropical zone
was covered with tree ferns
dense tropical forests did not grow as a
mass
there were no organisms back then that
would help wood decompose that is why
bulky trunks of trees didn't trot when
they died and didn't pass any nutrients
to their descendants
they remained lying without decaying and
the phosphorus in their bodies so vital
for plants couldn't be extracted thus
with time lush sapi verger gave way to
enormous heaps of dead wood covering
enormous stretches of land
later they formed rich deposits of coal
which is still widely used by mankind in
various industries
in areas other than the tropics only
fungi mosses and lichens could be found
they were not able to harden the upper
layer of the earth by their roots
and as a result rain easily washed it
off with rivers turning into muddy
streams and lakes becoming putrid swamps
dry areas became lifeless deserts
it was a time when fishes were
vigorously evolving in the seas and
rivers although life hadn't yet ventured
out into the open ocean
algae hadn't learned to float yet
and so life was still confined to
coastal areas
the carboniferous period was followed by
the permian period
it began
299 and finished
252 million years ago
the first amphibians dared to start
exploring land and plants spread to
conquer subtropics
the sea remained populated only in
shallow waters close to the coasts
the permian period finished with the
most massive extinction event in the
history of multicellular life according
to some estimates up to 96 of marine
species and 73 of land species died out
it is still not known what caused such a
global mortality
the triassic period of the mesozoic era
promptly made up for the lost time
bringing life to a new level during the
process
for the first time in history of the
earth temperate latitudes could boast
some woods
another revolutionary event took place
in the sea where blue green algae
emerged a type resembling their today's
descendants
it was not vital for them to live in a
substrate anymore and so photosynthetic
microorganisms quickly spread across the
upper layer of the global ocean
tempted by the food fishes mollusks and
arthropods followed it
organic leftovers settled on the sea
bottom thus sea bottom dwellers were
amply supplied with food as well
the global ocean was assuming an aspect
close to today's
the mesozoic era lasted from 250 to 66
million years ago
it is subdivided into three periods the
triassic the jurassic and the cretaceous
this is when dinosaurs thrived
admittedly the most well-known
prehistoric creatures that became
subject of feature and science fiction
movies
the way these ages are depicted we might
get the idea that the earth was covered
with tropical forests from the poles to
the equator
in fact it is completely wrong
indeed forests reached northern
latitudes but only because the average
temperature on the planet was much
higher than it is now
meanwhile equatorial areas on the
contrary suffered droughts
with the forests rapidly spreading
across the entire earth's surface there
were still lots of swamps and deserts
around
the latters were not only scorching hot
and dry as we're used to picturing them
but also moderate cool and even humid
with no herbaceous plants around soils
could not attach themselves to rocky
slopes
only lichens are able to grow on barren
rocks
flowering plants became abundant only by
the middle of the cretaceous period
that is around a hundred million years
ago
interestingly the first varieties were
trees and by the end of the period there
emerged plants similar to today's herbs
compared to a mighty oak or a giant
sequoia
regular grass appears insignificant
but it is capable of something tree
giants aren't
by mingling their tiny roots on the
ground they help form and strengthen the
turf this not only makes soil tougher
and prevents it from getting washed off
or eroding but also takes care of
getting rid of excess water by letting
it evaporate and accumulating water when
there is a lack of it on emerging
herbaceous plants turned deserts into
steps prairies and savannas swamps into
flood meadows and permafrost areas into
tundra and tundra step
by the time the cretaceous period was
coming to its end
the earth had started to resemble the
earth of today
it was lacking just one important touch
mammals
this type of animals had been around for
a long while
but the creatures were not very
widespread until the end of the mesozoic
era
it is still not clear what caused
dinosaurs to become extinct a giant
meteorite global cooling and other
suggestions are listed among the
supposed culprits
either way
these giant saurians vanished thus
vacating a special niche for mammals it
took them 66 million years to evolve
from tiny marsupials into majestic
whales dangerous tigers tough camels and
amusing bats
eventually evolution produced a unique
species
the only living creature capable of not
only adapting to nature but also
changing it
the being that extracts coal formed of
all those dead trees from millions of
years ago to warm up one's dwelling
the creature exterminating other species
for money of a sport
the creature turning vast areas into
wasteland in pursuit of selfish motives
this is homo sapiens or the human
life on our planet originated in water
this assumption forms the basis of the
biogenesis theory today and is
practically beyond any doubt in the
scientific community
it is water in its liquid state that
offers the best conditions for life to
originate and evolve in
however if we were to cast our gaze
around we would see various organisms
not only in oceans and rivers but also
on the planet's surface in the soil
in the lower strata of the atmosphere
and even in the mouths of volcanoes
when and why did life break away from
the hospitable ocean and move on to
exploring forbidding barren land
let's try to get to the bottom of it
up until the late proterozoic eon all
life on the earth was to be found only
in oceans
throughout that prehistoric period land
on the surface of the planet would
alternately be covered first by giant
ice caps then by barren lifeless
expanses similar to martian landscapes
and back again
ediacaran the last period in the
proterozoic
started approximately
635 million years ago and persisted for
94 million years
the earth of the time was far from being
the most hospitable place
if today's human were to experience the
environment of that period
he or she would very soon pass out due
to asphyxiation
as oxygen concentration in the air was
twice as low back then as it is now
landscapes of the diachron period were
endless deserts and rocky mountains
devoid of any signs of life meanwhile
the coastal area of the ocean was
crawling with highly unusual creatures
not even remotely resembling any of
today
they were mainly soft-bodied and
non-motile that is they couldn't move
around and fed of nutritious particles
in water
these organisms supposedly didn't have
either muscles or a developed nervous
system or a hard carapace
with practically no predators around all
these things were by the long and the
short of it not yet called for
predators emerged at the very end of the
ediacaran period at once establishing
their dominance in the prehistoric ocean
active hunting proved to be a highly
effective survival strategy as the
soft-bodied non-motile dwellers of the
ocean's bottom unable to either escape
from the enemy or put up a decent fight
or even hide were easy prey
in a way
the ocean was an endless smorgasbord for
first predators full of nutritious food
right there for the taking
it is hardly surprising that most
prehistoric creatures making up the menu
didn't last long
others had to adapt to deal with the new
dangers
[Music]
approximately
542 million years ago there began a
period that was to greatly contribute to
changing what our planet was like
geological layers of that time are
filled with fossils that used to be
highly organized living creatures
these vines give grounds to suppose that
the prehistoric ocean used to be teeming
with creatures sporting an impressive
outer skeleton or carapace
referred to as the cambrian explosion
the process heralded a new breakthrough
in the history of evolution of life on
our planet and the beginning of the
phanerozoic eon or the eon of visible
life
the first period of the phanerozoic eon
is called cambrian
it started
542 million years ago and continued for
about 56 million years
trilobites are the most well-known and
widespread creatures of the time
although these creepy things are not the
only ones the cambrian is notable for
this was the period when the prey
predator system was finally established
it goes without saying that in the
millions of years that followed natural
conditions would interfere with the
established food chains with some
species dying out and others riding high
but the principle stayed
predation became a potent incentive for
evolution which forced organisms to
change in order to be able to deal with
new threats as well as to explore new
areas so far inaccessible to predators
[Music]
the cambrian explosion produced a great
many completely new forms of
organization of living organisms
many of them didn't prove to be viable
and eventually vanished off the face of
the earth
others on the other hand brought about a
great diversity of new species
for example approximately five hundred
fifty five hundred thirty million years
ago tiny bottom dwellers resembling
mollusks known as haiku wellers
developed a sturdy notochord going
through the entire body
these creatures are believed to be some
of the most ancient ancestors of today's
vertebrates
picayas came a bit later
these were not very large creatures
either
they looked like lancelets flatworms or
primitive fish
proud owners of a sturdy and flexible
cord with muscles attached to it they
were able to swim by wriggling their
entire body in a series of s-shaped
movements
this manner of swimming proved to be
quite effective and fast which allowed
early chordates to survive and evolve
into higher organized species
admittedly almost all paleontological
finds dating back to the cambrian are
those of marine dwellers as the
overwhelming majority of the living
organisms of that period lived in the
ocean
some of these creatures we can see in
fossil finds look highly peculiar and
even horrifying
anomalocaris for example was a giant
shrimp measuring up to 60 centimeters in
length
it was also one of the apex predators in
the cambrian period and even though
other fines appear rather bleak in
comparison they are proof of some really
important phenomena
among these the most ancient fossil
finds of land soils can be mentioned
they date back to around 530 million
years ago which corresponds to the
middle and late cambrian without any
specific knowledge in the field one will
fail to see anything special in these
ordinary looking stones
however these prints show that it was
around this time that first primitive
algae and microorganisms started to
venture onto land
later having thrived in their lifetime
they died and decomposed thus forming a
nutritious substrate for their
descendants
first colonies of microorganisms must
have formed in humid and warm places on
land
in shallow waters for example or in the
tidal zone of the ocean with plenty of
water and light
and with no animals around that would be
keen on eating them
young algae flourished successfully
adapting to the new conditions
single cell algae was soon joined by
primitive fungi which were not able to
synthesize nutrients on their own but
could feed on what remained of dead
weeds
a hundred million years later the
symbiosis of fungi and single cell algae
produced lichens
these undemanding things were to become
tip of the spear in exploring great
expanses of new territories
the ordovician period which followed the
cambrian began approximately
485 million years ago and continued for
around 42 million years this is when
marine life was actively evolving
in the ocean mollusks and arthropods
were thriving among the latter's
euriptarids
many of which dwell to the bottom
to get around more conveniently these
creatures used their jointed limbs
this feature would later be an
indispensable asset and an important
factor in adaptation to life on land
apart from these there evolved jawless
animals similar to today's lump rays and
a bit later their emerged cartilage fish
meanwhile
plants slowly but surely made their way
inland and away from water first
multicellular plants emerged which were
clearly able to survive on land
they left imprints of spores and vessels
that delivered water to the upper parts
of the plants animals on the other hand
still didn't venture out of their
regular environment although it is
probable that some crustaceans did have
a chance to explore coastal areas
this period ended in the ordovician
silurian extinction event its causes are
still not clearly defined yet
but according to the most popular theory
it was brought about by global ice age
and a fall in the level of the global
ocean that followed
be it as it may
up to 50 percent of all the species
vanished off the face of the earth as a
result of the extinction
however life was able to adapt to new
conditions and even take it to a
completely new level
next in line was the silurian period
which continued from 444
to 409 million years ago
this was when giant arthropods dominated
the ocean and it is then that one might
come across a euryptorid measuring up to
two and a half meters in length
fishes also thrived among which large
and swift predators over one meter long
come to think of it it is hardly
surprising that some living creatures
preferred to leave the ocean and try to
find other safer areas for their
habitats
and so this is when first arthropods
came on shore
these were prehistoric europeans and
other crustaceans
their tough chitinous carapace protected
them from exposure to the sun and drying
as well as kept their body in shape
their small legs allowed them to move
around on hard surfaces when out of
water
it is reasonable to suppose that first
arthropods that ventured on land made a
point of not getting too far from water
their respiratory organs had to remain
moist in order to function correctly
however the arthropods were greatly
tempted by the abundance of plant food
that was therefore the taking just
beside the sea
the safety factor guaranteed by land was
another attraction as predators hadn't
yet learned to chase their prey if the
latter escaped to land
gradually these explorers fully adapted
to the new conditions and came onto land
for good which later made for an
incredible diversity of species among
insects and spiders as well as other
classes of living creatures
approximately 419 million years ago the
devonian period began which was the most
important one in terms of land
exploration
it lasted for around 60 million years
this is when rhinophytes spread all over
the planet prehistoric vascular plants
and ancestors of
mosses and ferns
reaching three meters in height they
densely covered all humid and warm
places of the planet
mainly coastal areas of seas and the
deltas of rivers flowing into them
however neither rhinophytes nor mosses
and lichens that emerged later had a
proper root system instead of a network
of roots that would keep a plant firmly
in place they are just primitive root
stocks at best
that is why soils would quickly get
washed into rivers and turn them into
muddy streams and their deltas into
swamps
in these humid places rich in organic
matter plants were flourishing
giving food to insects and other
inhabitants of the earth of that time
fish in their turn were attracted to
marshy areas by the abundance of insects
and their larvae eventually great
amounts of putrefying organic matter
absorbed oxygen from the water in swamps
which affected the breathing of the
creatures living there
that is why to compensate for the lack
of oxygen fish in those waters learned
to take gulps of atmospheric air
gradually they developed a breathing sac
allowing them to survive outside their
aquatic habitat
simultaneously other appendages were
developing
thick stalks and trunks of plants
growing in marshes offered to fish
reliable shelter from larger predators
however it was hard for them to make
their way through these thickets
thin fins were not adequate for the
purpose
more powerful and muscular limbs were
called for
that is how the fins of fish dwelling in
marshy environments grew longer and
developed additional bones that strong
muscles were attached to these were
first lung fish and in particular
psychopterygie
eustinopterin is a typical
representative of these even though this
strong finned fish wasn't keen on
settling on land it was already able to
breathe atmospheric air and stay out of
water for certain periods
shallow swamps would often dry out
which is why their inhabitants would
have to migrate to other more humid
places favorable for life
and to do this they naturally had to
move across stretches of land
this is the way acanthostega got about
it for example
which lived around
365 million years ago in the late
devonian
one of the first known creatures
intermediate between fish and amphibians
acantha steger had gills scales and a
tail fin just like any other fish
at the same time this fascinating
creature sported four legs and a
breathing sack like that of amphibians
that allowed it to breathe atmospheric
air unfortunately acanthus steger's
limbs were not strong enough to support
its weight
and its thorax muscles couldn't pump
oxygen for too long
that is why it stayed mostly in water
sometimes crawling from one body of
water to take a dunk in another
gradually the ability of prehistoric
sarcopteryji to breathe atmospheric air
improved their fins grew in power and
turned into fully fledged pores
their appearance underwent great changes
for example tiktaalik a prehistoric
sarcopterygian amphibian fish that lived
at around the same time as a kantha
steger had a flat head like that of a
frog
being anatomically intermediate between
fish and amphibians tiktaalik had
powerful fins that were able to prop up
its body and move it across solid
surfaces
in addition this amphibian fish could
breathe with both its gills and its
lungs the way its ossicle is designed is
proof of tiktaalik's ability to easily
distinguish sounds both on land and in
water all these signs show that this
creature spent as much time out of water
as in it
in the carboniferous period which
followed the devonian
amphibians came onto land for good
settling in all sorts of ecological
niches in their revolutionary struggle
they developed into such animal classes
as reptiles and synapsids a great
diversity of conditions outside the
ocean
stimulated and spurred the evolutionary
process on as land dwellers are exposed
to a much wider range of temperatures
and other factors than water dwellers
incidentally this question may arise why
did animals come onto land only once in
the entire history of evolution why
didn't a single marine species venture
to live on land in the past
350 million years the answer isn't as
elaborate as it might seem
[Music]
marine creatures are adapted to living
in an aquatic habitat
the overwhelming majority of them are
useless and actually helpless when out
of water
to live in another environment they
would need a whole other skeleton
structure as well as outer skin or fur
or shell for that matter and organs of
breathing vision and hearing the
proverbial fish out of water is even
more helpless than a human in the open
sea it is a foregone conclusion that
stranded fish is there for the taking
for any land creature that would care to
have it
when coming onto land in the paleozoic
period plants arthropods and vertebrates
went on to occupy vacant ecological
niches
they didn't have natural enemies in the
new environment
while there was plenty of food around
the chief negative factor in the new
environment was not other creatures but
other conditions fortunately the species
were able to take their time adapting to
them interestingly an example of the
other way around is known to us
prehistoric ancestors of cetacea
went back to living in an aquatic
environment at the same time dominating
certain ecological niches
strange though it may seem on the face
of it there is actually nothing
controversial about it
the fact is that things to adapt to in
the terrestrial environment are tougher
and more diverse that is why getting
back in the water could be a smart move
in order to survive
whales dolphins and other secondary
aquatic inhabitants of oceans seas and
rivers are living evidence confirming
the fact that evolution is not
irreversible if in certain circumstances
it is better to take a step back
that's what it will do
the permian triassic extinction event
marked the beginning of the mesozoic
a new era in the geologic history of the
earth
it began approximately
252 million years ago and continued for
around
186 million years
this was a time when our planet was
actively transforming and gradually
assuming it's today's looks
the most crucial tectonic process of the
epoch was the splitting of the single
supercontinent pangaea
first it broke down into two landmasses
laurasia and gondwana which in their
turn went on to form the continents we
know today
with several large mutually independent
territories separated by seas and
straits the conditions were perfect for
independent ecosystems to emerge which
gave impetus to new evolutionary
adaptations
in terms of climate the mesozoic was the
warmest era in the entire history of
multicellular life forms
throughout this era there was no ice
shield even at the pearls that would
cover the ground for a long term
still temperature would drop from time
to time which forced both flora and
fauna to adapt to the newly imposed
conditions
the mesozoic comprises three periods and
the first one is known as the triassic
it began around
252 million years ago and continued for
around 51 million years
this was the time when tectonic
processes in the earth's interior were
just starting to break pangaea into
separate continents and the
supercontinent remained whole for most
of the period
the ural ridge one of the oldest
mountain ridges existing to this day
completed its formation in the triassic
at the time the mountains were in their
solid days and comparatively high
the period's climate was relatively dry
and hot which is why there were lots of
deserts at the time and the area of
inland bodies of water diminished there
was 10 to 15 percent of oxygen in the
air for most of the triassic and then
around 215 million years ago its level
gave a sudden leap to reach as much as
19
the reasons for this phenomenon haven't
been established for certain but it is
assumed that it may have had something
to do with the evolution and spreading
of certain varieties of marine or land
plants
prehistoric seed ferns accounted for the
overwhelming majority of the flora of
the day but later on they were gradually
ousted by more progressive groups of
plants
those included psyches ginkgo and
prehistoric conifers
many of these orders have survived our
day although now they're not as diverse
as they used to be
marine life meanwhile was following its
own course of evolution the oceans
emptied by the perm triassic extinction
were gradually populated by turtles and
teleasts and the first ichthyosaurus
held the niche of large predators
later on they were to become reptiles
best adapted to aquatic environment
but in the triassic these creatures were
still rather primitive
an example of these is symbol spondulis
which lived 240 to 210 million years ago
this giant sea saurian measured 6 to 10
meters in length and date mostly fish
this impressive creature had a long thin
body half of which was a flexible tail
its head was rather large and the
elongated sharp muzzle boasted a nice
set of small and sharp teeth
symbol spondulis's limbs looked like
diving fins but it appears they were
used only to stabilize body position in
water
the saurian's skeleton structure
suggests that it traveled through water
by making wave-like movements and
generally speaking was rather clumsy
the most common representatives of
landfauna of that time were raccosauria
prehistoric ancestors of dinosaurs
crocodile amorphous and birds as well as
other animal species
by the middle of the period first
dinosaurs evolved from ancient
archesauria as independent species but
there was still a long and hard struggle
for survival up ahead for them
it was only by the end of the triassic
that dinosaurs started to establish
their dominance in the earth's biosphere
after sharply growing in size which
incidentally coincided with an increase
of oxygen in the atmosphere
with dozens of films and thousands of
books about horrifying saurians anyone
today would be familiar with what they
looked like
at the same time these giants seem to
eclipse other species which are by no
means less important and interesting
for example oligocythus
a small creature that lived in the late
triassic around 200 million years ago
this small and deft little animal was a
genus of cyanodance
prehistoric animals that differed from
mammals in some not very clearly
noticeable traits
oligocyphus had a thin flexible body
measuring around 50 centimeters
it grew fur and generally looked like a
weasel
warm blooded and herbivorous it was
widespread on the territories of today's
north america europe and china
even though it isn't known whether
oligocyphus had a pouch on its stomach
the structure of its skeleton allows us
to assume that its babies were quite
small which is typical of today's
marsupials it is also highly likely that
oligocyphus fed its babies on milk
another assumption about these creatures
is that they dug boroughs and made homes
there they also took great care about
their babies which may be evidence of a
comparatively high intellect
unfortunately these creatures perished
at the beginning of the jurassic period
supposedly due to lack of food and
heightened competition still they remain
the oldest prehistoric animals that look
like today's mammals most
the triassic jurassic mass extinction
heralded the end of the triassic period
a great number of amphibians some
arcusauria other reptiles as well as
many plant orders vanished from the face
of the earth
among the possible reasons for this
disaster of volcanic activity a change
in the global ocean level and sudden
climate change
either way the extinction event vacated
a number of ecological niches which
allowed dinosaurs to establish a firmer
position on the evolutionary arena of
the earth
the next period of the mesozoic was the
jurassic
it began about 201 million years ago and
ended about
145 million years ago which makes it
roughly 56 million years long this was a
time of large scale tectonic movements
and reformations
it is in the jurassic that the
supercontinent pangaea finally split to
form several land masses mutually
separated by shallow seas
if we look at the map of the earth at
the end of the jurassic period we'll be
able to distinguish the shapes of some
of today's continents although they
would be positioned in unexpected places
since the new continents were mutually
independent their emerged isolated
biosystems
that is why some animals and plants that
were abundant on one continent would be
non-existent on another
the earth's climate was warm and humid
for most of the jurassic period and by
its end a comparatively short cooling
occurred
great areas on land were covered with
tropical forests which were for the most
part psychists
to tresembled palm trees
conifers were also widespread
their looks were reminiscent of today's
cypress trees and pine trees
on land meanwhile there started the
epoch when dinosaurs positively
flourished their diversity was rich and
they held most ecological niches while
dominating almost every single one of
them
among these creatures one could come
across both small saurians the size of a
cat and real giants
herbivorous dinosaurs known as sauropoda
came to be widespread in the jurassic
with some typical representatives like
brachiosaurus brontosaurus diplodocus
and others they resembled each other
very much
the largest one titanosaurus measured as
much as 25 to 30 meters in length and
could weigh over 75 tons
an unusual feature typical of sauropoda
is the so-called sacral brain
a widening in the hind part of the
vertebrae that hypothetically could
contain 20 times more nervous tissue
than cranial brain
today it is posited that the sacral
cavity was likely to be filled with a
glycogen body which was a source of
additional nutrition for the giant
saurian's nervous system
alongside dinosaurs other animal species
were evolving as well
such as mammals reptiles and darth
reports
the oceans were richly populated with
bivalve mollusks
which in many ways resembled their
today's descendants
the apex predators in the marine food
chain were various saurians like
ichthyosaurus and pliosaurus
looking at a thalmasaurus which lived at
the beginning and the end of the
jurassic period and comparing it with
symbol spondulis which lived earlier it
may be hard to believe that these
animals are in fact related
ancestor
symbol spondulous
lived 240 to 210 million years ago
length 6 to 10 meters
elongated body and head
badly adapted to aquatic environment
descendant of thalmasaurus
lived 165 to 145 million years ago
length
up to 6 meters streamlined body vertical
tail
well adapted to aquatic environment
this marine saurian had a dolphin-like
body with an elegant and powerful
crescent-shaped vertical tail
it is thought that the animal breathed
atmospheric air and was able to stay
around 20 minutes under water develop
speeds of over seven kilometers per hour
and dive as deep as 600 meters
judging by ophthalmosol's teeth
structure its diet consisted for the
main part of molluscs including squid
the animal's eyes were another
distinctive feature in its appearance
their diameter measured around 10
centimeters and they were protected by a
bony sclerotic ring
it is thought that a thalmosaurus could
see well in the dark which was a
valuable asset for deep water hunt and
so the animal was free to dive far down
where larger saurian predators couldn't
get
the last period of the mesozoic era is
called the cretaceous it began
145 million years ago and lasted for
around 79 million years which makes it
the longest one in the mesozoic
the continents continued to break apart
throughout the entire cretaceous india
detached itself from africa and slowly
drifted in the direction of asia across
the indian ocean south america broke
away as well and made its way westwards
eventually by the end of the period
africa australia greenland north and
south america assumed shapes close to
those of today while europe and asia
were starting to get clearly defined
borders
the climate in the cretaceous was
comparatively cool in the period from
100 to 85 million years ago the average
temperature increased somewhat and then
cooling continued which persisted till
the very end of the era
this is exactly when tyrannosaurus and
triceratops were around
the most widely known dinosaurs and
truly distinctive symbols of the
mesozoic
still the period is much more notable
for the spread of flowering plants
first trees and then grasses
they form turf and so strengthened the
soils and made them more fertile while
nutritious seeds served as food for a
wide variety of species
this gave evolutionary impetus to
diversification of mammal species and
also for some herbivorous dinosaurs but
on a smaller scale
even though reptiles were dominating in
all the ecological niches of that time
mammals continued to evolve
they grew to be more and more diverse
and by the end of the period it was
possible to single out separate groups
like congulates ulipo typhla predators
and primates
reponomas which lived around
125 million years ago was one of the
largest mammals of the cretaceous
its body measured up to 1 meter in
length and it weighed 12 to 14 kilograms
this creature's appearance may have been
similar to today's tasmanian devils
its teeth structure suggests that it was
a predator but its limbs were short and
clumsy so probably this animal was a
scavenger
incidentally an interesting find was
unearthed to archaeological diggings
it was rapidnomus's skeleton with bits
of a small dinosaur in its abdominal
area
this may serve as evidence that some
mammals of the time could hunt small
dinosaur species like cetacosaurus and
darkyorn ethys
meanwhile large aquatic saurians had
long been dominating the seas
ichthyosaurus plesiosaurus and
mosasaurus
however around 1995 million years ago
their population sharply dropped after
the extinction event brought about by
the second oceanic anoxic event which
had to do with a sharp decrease of
oxygen in the ocean one of the suggested
possible reasons is increased under
water volcanic activity
the end of the cretaceous was probably
the coldest time in the mesozoic
all living creatures set about adapting
to the inexorably dropping temperatures
and dinosaurs were no exception
around 70 million years ago the
territory of today's northern alaska
above the arctic circle was inhabited by
peculiar dinosaur species
this sauron is known as nanuxorus
remotely related to the horrifying giant
tyrannosaurus rex this dinosaur
admittedly resembled it but its size was
smaller
the body of nanuksaurus measured around
6 meters and it weighed just around a
thousand kilos that is approximately
eight nine times less than tyrannosaurus
rex
this shrinking is thought to have had to
do with a lack of available food in its
habitats
forced to survive in the dire conditions
of the far north among snowy stretches
and in the semi-darkness of the polar
night
this dinosaur developed some unusual
features
first of all it is likely that it was
warm blooded and incidentally the
metabolic processes in its body ran
their course remarkably fast for example
as is the case with today's birds
secondly nanuxoris body was covered with
several layers of down and feathers
which allowed it to preserve warmth in
the severe northern climate
this suggests that the northern saurian
was probably an active and fast-moving
predator but in the conditions of the
polar knight traditional ways of hunting
prey are not that effective that is why
it appears that nanooksaurus had an
exceptionally well developed sense of
smell and sensitive night vision
these assumptions are confirmed by the
build of its cranium
summer in northern latitudes was short
and rather cool so additional sources of
warmth were needed for dinosaur eggs so
that the babies developed well
nanooksaurus is thought to hatch its
eggs and to take great care about the
young ones
studies of fossil finds show that the
volume of the brain of this species was
rather big potentially this dinosaur was
as intelligent as most of today's birds
unfortunately these evolutionary
adaptations didn't save nanuksaurus from
extinction around 66 million years ago
the cretaceous paleogene extinction
event caused all non-avian dinosaurs to
vanish off the face of the earth
alongside marine saurians pterosaurs and
many other species
still the terrifying saurians left their
imprint in the history of our planet and
the ecological niches vacated by them
were promptly occupied by birds and
mammals
this marked the beginning of the
cenozoic era its highest being was the
unique creature that came to be known as
homo sapiens the self-proclaimed king
above all nature
its evolution has only just started and
time will show what it has in store for
this species
three-fourths of all living organisms on
earth died out in the cretaceous
paleogene extinction almost all
creatures heavier than 25 kilos ceased
to be including practically all
non-avian dinosaurs
this tragic event heralded the end of
the mesozoic and the beginning of the
cenozoic the geologic era that is still
not over it is divided into three
periods of various duration which are
different both in terms of climate and
diversity of the biosphere
the first and longest is known as the
paleogene
it began around 66 million years ago and
continued for 43 million years
in the first 10 million years of the
paleogene the earth's biosphere was
recovering from the hard blow dealt by
the mass extinction
this geological epoch is referred to as
the paleocene
since great numbers of dinosaurs and
other species of the cretaceous had
perished there were lots of vacant
ecological niches for the taking these
were promptly filled by the new masters
of our planet
mammals
the geography of the earth of that
period was drastically different from
what we're used to seeing today
looking at a map of that prehistoric
earth we would already be able to make
out the familiar continents but they
were positioned slightly differently
thus north and south americas were
separated by tropical seas while the
indian subcontinent was just starting to
make for the asian shores
the prehistoric ocean known as the
tethys still lay between africa and
eurasia but was already largely giving
way due to the movements of tectonic
plates the climate of the epoch was
warmer and more stable than today's most
of the planet was covered with dense and
lush tropical forests
the overwhelming majority of the living
creatures of the day were quite small
thanks to the abundance of vegetable
food they quickly propagated and spread
across more and more new areas this is
when the prehistoric ancestors of most
of today's mammals thrived
for example the warm forests of the
paleogene were inhabited by my acids
small and deft predators that looked
like martins it is believed that they
were the progenitors of all today's rich
diversity of mammal predators
at around the same time their lived rko
seats the prehistoric ancestors of
today's whales at the time however they
looked more like hippos they hadn't gone
to live in the sea yet but had made
their first steps in that direction
their limbs respiratory organs in the
inner rear had already started to adapt
to prolonged stays underwater
the next deparka planet went through was
the ear scene
it began approximately 56 million years
ago and continued for slightly over 22
million years the contours of the
continents had already grown to be quite
recognizable
india had finally made it to the
southern shores of asia and as a result
of the collision of tectonic plates
giant rock folds formed
that is how the himalayas rose
the largest mountain range on our planet
today
even though some species of that time
already looked like some we might come
across today others were completely
different
an example of one of these is andrew
sarkis
one of the largest mammal predators that
has ever lived on the earth
its skull measured up to 84 centimeters
which is roughly one and a half times
more than that of the brown bear and its
bite is estimated to have been harder
than that of any of today's land
predators
it has been inferred from the deep tooth
sockets in andrew sarkis's skull where
mandible muscles were attached to which
leaves no doubts as to the bite's
crushing force
reconstruction of its skeleton shows
that the animal could measure over 4
meters in length and weigh as much as a
ton
still interestingly it looks like this
giant carnivore fell into the class of
primitive ungulates
research showed that andrew sarkis's
closest relatives were the prehistoric
sewer forms hippopotamus and cetaceans
studies of a few unearthed fossils of
its skull and teeth show that the animal
must have been omnivorous and even
didn't mind eating carrion
unfortunately not many bones and fossils
of this fascinating creature have been
found
and scientists are still at odds as to
the structure of its organism habits and
relation to other mammal families
the oligoscene was the last debuck of
the paleogene it is posited that it
began around 33.9 million years ago and
was over about 23 million years ago
which makes it roughly 11 million years
long
this was a time of global cooling
warm tropical forests were gradually
superseded by endless prairies covered
with grasslands
this is when the antarctic glaciation
began and an icy shield transformed the
green continent of the pole into a
lifeless cold desert
australia continued to drift away from
the other continents while africa on the
contrary was making for the north to
meet europe
after a collision of tectonic plates
mountain ranges formed and that is how
the alps made their appearance on the
map of the world
around 26 28 million years ago the super
volcano lagarita furiously erupted on
the territory of today's colorado
in fact it was one of the major volcanic
emissions of the entire phanerozoic eon
an area of over 30 000 square meters was
buried under a layer of hot ash as much
as a hundred meters thick
all life within a huge radius around the
volcano was destroyed completely
amazingly
life is able to come to terms with any
disasters the earth of the time was
inhabited by fascinating creatures some
of which were not smaller than dinosaurs
in size for example indrich etherium a
prehistoric herbivore related to rhinos
paraceratherium the largest of these
reached 4.8 meters in shoulder length
which is higher than a large african
elephant
thanks to their remarkably long neck
these giants were able to raise their
head up to 7 meters above the ground
today's rhino would be able to pass
under its enormous progenitor's belly
while a human would hardly reach up to
touch its knee
with our mass reaching 20 tons these
giants were the largest land mammals of
all times
even brontosaurus the most massive of
land dinosaurs weighed just around 15
tons it still hasn't been established
for certain what endrick ethereum looked
like unfortunately
not one entire skeleton of these amazing
animals has been excavated so far only
separate fragments from different
animals of the species
most scientists agree that in spite of
their relation to rhinos enduric
ethereum didn't have a massive horn
although it may well have had a small
nose trunk like today's tapias
the trunk would have allowed it to pick
juicy leaves off treetops
these giant herbivores must have lived
in small herds and were constantly on
the move around vast stretches of land
roaming across their dominions in search
of food
unfortunately by the end of the
oligoscene indrik ethereum had died out
completely
at around the same time the areas they
used to inhabit were explored by
prehistoric elephants alongside large
predators hyena dance and amphicyonids
the latters are also known as bear dogs
it is thought that the emergence of new
large herbivores would have greatly
upset nature's balance and intricate
theorem would have been forced to
fiercely compete for its food
famine and the threat from the new
dwellers of the asian prairie gradually
led to the herbivores giant's total
extinction apart from those mentioned
there were some other large predators
who were quite common on the earth and
the period from 37.2 to 28.4 million
years ago
and telodons fossilized remains of these
creatures have been found all over
eurasia being even toed ungulates and
telodons resembled wild boars although
in terms of evolution these creatures
are closer to hippos or even cetaceans
measuring up to two meters in length
they weighed over a ton a meter long
head had huge jaws complete with all
sorts of teeth
sharp in sizes long fangs and wide flat
moles it is likely that intelligence
were omnivores with a preference for
predation not hampered by their
impressive size and bulk they were able
to develop remarkably high speeds so
chances of outrunning such a monster
were quite thin
a wild boar the size of a large bull
that prefers meat posed a serious threat
to any inhabitant of the earth of that
time
that is why it is hardly surprising that
intellidons successfully struggled for
their survival for such a considerable
time
the period in the history of our earth
that came next was the near gene
it began approximately 23 million years
ago and ended just two million five
hundred and eighty thousand years ago
this is when our planet started to look
almost but not quite what it looks like
today
the continents shifted to their today's
positions on the planet's surface and
the looks of the most of the plants and
animals of the day grew to be familiar
to our eye with the earth's climate
gradually becoming colder and with
droughts occurring more often polar caps
were gradually growing which culminated
in a global glaciation at the end of the
neogene
the planet meanwhile was crawling with
all sorts of fascinating creatures
the deep sea dwellers were terrorized by
megalodon a giant shark measuring 15
meters in length and weighing up to 35
tons
on land
various gomphotheriums could be seen
creatures related to today's elephants
many of them were the proud owners of
four solid tusks as for the animal size
some were larger than today's african
elephant whereas others were quite
modest in comparison
around 2.5 million years ago there
started the quaternary which is
currently the last geologic period in
the history of the earth it is
remarkable for the emergence and
evolution of homo sapiens as well as its
prehistoric ancestors
for example in the period from one
million years ago to a hundred thousand
years ago there lived gigantopithecus
one of the species of great human-like
apes known to science they measured
three to four meters in height and
weighed over 500 kilograms these
creatures lived on the territory of asia
and were related to today's orangutans
it appears that gigantopithecus would
not be able to climb trees like other
human-like apes on account of its mass
however some of them are known to have
dwelt in mountainous areas and made
homes and natural grottos caves and
ravines even though their diet is
believed to have consisted of mainly
bamboo
bones of herbivorous animals with tooth
marks were unearthed in their shelters
judging by these finds it is safe to
assume that these creatures didn't mind
meat and were omnivorous at the very
least the gigantopithecus skeleton is
similar to that of a gorilla so they
were likely to use all four limbs to
move around
besides these human-like apes had a
comparatively large brain which means
that they could be relatively
intelligent and were probably able to
even make primitive working tools
unfortunately the population of these
amazing giants sharply dropped when the
prehistoric ancestors of today's human
emerged and spread across the planet
by around one to three hundred thousand
years ago they had died out completely
sadly not many remains of
gigantopithecus have been found which
greatly impedes studying them
as they were spreading across the earth
primitive human tribes eliminated many
other creatures
other giants who supposedly became
extinct because of humans were
diprotodons which inhabited australia in
the period from 1.6 million years ago to
around 40 000 years ago
these creatures were the largest known
marsupials and they were related to
wombats and koalas some of these amazing
animals reached as much as three meters
in length and two meters in shoulder
height as for the hamas they weighed
approximately three tons
this makes diprotodons quite as big as
some hippos
massive and herbivorous they dwelt on
massive woodland and coastal
grass-covered plains that abounded in
australia before humans had made their
appearance there
chronologically the extinction of the
marsupial giants coincides with first
human tribes arriving to this continent
still some scientists maintained that
the extinction was caused not by hunting
but an anomaly of the earth's magnetic
field together with a local temperature
decrease the heightened radiation
background coupled with cooling slowed
down plant growth which led to farming
among the herbivores
thus it appears that by and large the
tragedy was inevitable and the humans
simply brought it to a close faster
the last ebook of the quaternary the
holocene heralded a robust development
of the human civilization when homo
sapiens spread across the entire planet
and dominated all the other inhabitants
of our earth the downside of this
evolution is manifested in a number of
industrial disasters and irreversible
changes in nature's balance
for example it is due to human activity
that the greenhouse gases concentration
in the earth's atmosphere is getting
worse every year
this may globally negatively affect all
living things on our earth from simplest
bacteria
to elaborate multicellular organisms
unfortunately the number of fascinating
creatures living on our earth is going
down every year it is particularly
poignant to realize that they perish
because of human stupidity or ovaries
uncontrolled hunting irresponsible land
development and indifference to the
environment have already made scientists
speak of a new
sixth great extinction event
whose consequences are potentially just
as grave as those of the previous five
will mankind stop before it eliminates
itself
how long should it take our planet to
recover from the consequences of the
technological progress
and will nature produce radically new
life forms that would weather this
crisis
just like it happened before
we can hardly realistically answer these
questions
[Music]
the evolution of life on earth was
anything but linear there were periods
of higher diversity as well as periods
of almost total extinction
this was deduced following the analysis
of fossils unearthed at paleontological
digging sites
in the past 540 million years there have
been five major and about 20 minor
extinction events
however the most global crisis of our
planet's biosphere occurred much earlier
approximately 2.1 billion years ago
the first living organisms are posited
to have appeared on earth rather early
approximately but not quite four billion
years ago
that is about 400 million years after
the planet's surface had become more or
less suitable for life
even so the earth of that period can't
have looked hospitable
barren rocks dense clouds frequent
storms and earthquakes and an atmosphere
devoid of oxygen made up of mostly
nitrogen methane and carbon dioxide
this was the age of primitive
microorganisms archaea and bacteria most
of which used an oxygenic photosynthesis
that is a kind of photosynthesis where
oxygen is not produced
apart from these creatures it is thought
that there were many forms falling in
between that couldn't be classified as
either living beings or not living
objects with a satisfying degree of
certainty
about 2.7 billion years ago their
emerged oxygenic photosynthesis the kind
of photosynthesis familiar to us where
oxygen is produced this form is still
used by the overwhelming majority of
plants and unicellular algae anaerobic
organisms cannot live in an oxygen-rich
environment that is why ancient algae
used oxygen as a weapon they released it
as a byproduct of their life activity
and this waste killed their competitors
this way algae not only protected their
turf but also spread further to cover
larger areas to dwell on
at first oxygen was spent on oxidation
of rocks in habitats of aerobic
organisms colonies
in this manner oxygen pockets were
formed
small areas of oxidized minerals
gradually oxygen went on to spread in
the atmosphere oxidizing methane sulphur
compounds and iron not able to exist in
an environment rich in oxygen most
anaerobic organisms died out with those
of them remaining around confined to
underground pockets where oxygen didn't
reach thus the tables were turned in the
biosphere with the oxygen breathing
organisms becoming the majority and
spreading across larger areas and the
former planet owners forced to remain in
some limited areas
with the spread of the new organisms the
content of gases like methane and carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere dropped
methane oxidized forming water and
eventually carbon dioxide with the
latter taking active part in
photosynthesis
all this reduced the greenhouse effect
and the earth's surface considerably
cooled
the so-called huronian glaciation
started approximately 2.1 billion years
ago and continued for about 300 million
years until the sun's luminosity and
tectonic makeovers had heated up the
earth this was a time when single cell
microorganisms were evolving extremely
slowly constantly thwarted by an
occasional prolonged global ice age the
period has earned a great number of
nicknames like the great oxidation or
oxygenation event oxygen catastrophe and
oxygen crisis to name but a few
even though not really swift this event
was definitely large scale and global
practically all the biodiversity of the
non-oxygen period was eliminated and
evolution was greatly hampered by global
glaciation for a good billion years
however in the aftermath there emerged a
more energy efficient method of
nutrition
approximately 540 million years ago the
phanerozoic eons started sometimes
referred to as the period of visible
life
it was peculiar for vigorous evolution
of multicellular species and in fact it
is actually still in progress
many creatures of that age looked really
bizarre and didn't resemble any of their
today's descendants
suddenly about 450 million years ago
some unknown factor abruptly interfered
with the act of evolution of life forms
the proposed causes include a cosmic
gamma-ray burst volcanic activity and
even a large celestial object impact as
it is from 25 to 50 percent of all
living beings became extinct within
seven million years
this series of extinction events dubbed
the ordovician silurian extinction was
hard on trilobites mollusks and some
other marine invertebrates of the time
the late paleozoic era that followed
this extinction event heralded active
evolution of flora on land
the first amphibians and reptiles
emerged in that time too fishes were
actively evolving establishing their
dominance in all fresh water and saline
bodies of water
approximately
372 million years ago the so-called
devonian extinction started it occurred
in several stages that were alternately
followed by comparatively peaceful
periods
peaceful they may have been but even so
the extinction rate of species was
higher than average
the most likely reason for this
extinction is posited to be this
land plants of the time sported long and
powerful roots which enabled them to
extract nutrients from much deeper down
in the soil than before
when waters seeped through soils that
were loosened by plants roots
great amounts of nutrients were washed
into the ocean
as a result algae were positively
thriving there in the abundance of food
and light
the rotting of these algae reduced
oxygen dissolved in the water and the
organisms inhabiting the sea bottom were
simply smothered with nothing to breathe
in the aftermath about 70 percent of the
marine species of that time are
estimated to have died out including
practically all species forming coral
reefs
this triggered global irreversible
changes in the biosphere of the global
ocean
many genera and families vanished
completely and the vacated space was
filled by others
in the carboniferous period which
followed tree ferns exploded in numbers
all over the planet's surface
also there emerged gymnosperm trees and
conifers
it is in this period that rich deposits
of coal were formed which is still
widely used by mankind and various
industries
speaking about the fauna this was the
time when insects thrived that's when
the giant millipede arthropleura was
around which measured two and a half
meters
the meganura a giant dragonfly with a
wingspan of up to one meter
and the boom in a scorpius a scorpion
measuring 70 centimeters
the insects were of these unbelievable
sizes on account of exceptionally high
concentrations of oxygen in the
atmosphere which at that time reached a
staggering 35 percent
the permian triassic extinction event
also informally referred to as the great
dying
occurred about 251 253 million years ago
marking the transition from the permian
to the triassic period
it proved to be the most massive and
global in the entire history of
multicellular life
digging show that up to 95 percent of
marine species and up to 70 percent of
land species vanished from the face of
the earth as a result
interestingly this disaster was rather
swift by geological standards
it took just up to 200 000 years
later it would take not less than 50
million years for biodiversity to
recover for land species and about a
hundred million years for marine species
trilobites a great number of marine and
vertebrates and microorganisms were on
the verge of extinction
insects shrank in size they stopped
looking like horror film creatures on
the loose and instead assumed in
appearance of today's tiny and numerous
creatures the reasons for the permian
triassic extinction event still haven't
been established with certainty
among the proposed hypotheses we may
single out robust volcanic activity as
one of the most likely ones
others worth mentioning are a collision
of our earth with a large celestial
object climate change and active methane
emissions following biological or
tectonic activities there is no single
answer to this question yet
in the triassic period which followed
the permian triassic extinction event
vertebrates vigorously evolved
this is when archosaurs emerged the
prehistoric saurians crocodiles and
dinosaurs were to evolve from
the triassic period also produced first
mammals although they were not so
widespread at that time
about 200 million years ago the triassic
jurassic extinction event began
sometimes called the end triassic
extinction having lasted for
approximately 10 000 years it marked the
transition from the triassic to the
jurassic period the event claimed about
half of known species on the earth of
that time
they included various reptiles and
amphibians that vacated a number of
ecological niches this allowed dinosaurs
to establish their dominance on the
planet and sustain it for the next
130 million years
incidentally the reasons for the
untriagic extinction event are not known
either
and in fact there isn't a single
hypothesis today that would sound
sufficiently convincing
the jurassic and cretaceous periods that
followed the triassic jurassic
extinction event were the times when
dinosaurs thrived and flourished but
these giant saurians were not the sole
inhabitants of our planet at the time
this is when the forefathers of today's
birds flowering plants and corals
evolved as well as small furry
warm-blooded animals
mammals
even though these small creatures didn't
look quite as impressive compared to
tremendous dinosaurs in all their glory
they firmly held their ecological ground
and steadily progressed in their
revolution
mammals got their chance at the end of
the cretaceous period
that is about 66 million years ago
what occurred then was the most
well-known and a rather large-scale mass
extinction event referred to as the
cretaceous tertiary extinction event
according to the first and most popular
hypothesis the extinction was caused by
a giant celestial object impact
everyone would have heard of a meteorite
supposedly killing off all dinos
nevertheless there is no hard evidence
in favor of this version either way the
upshot was that all dinosaurs died out
alongside a great number of conifers
algae and mollusks
the cretaceous tertiary extinction event
heralded the beginning of a new geologic
era the cenozoic which is still in
progress
throughout this era mammals birds and
flowering plants have been actively
evolving and spreading across the earth
mammals settled all over the planet
inhabiting it literally everywhere from
tropical areas to ice caps of the poles
and from the depths of the oceans and
the planet's interior to air currents up
high
eventually evolution produced mankind
even though you would expect people
today to be enlightened enough there are
still those who do not believe in
evolution
however the theory of evolution is not
something to believe in it is a
scientific theory based on facts
the theory of the evolution of species
has come a long way and has undergone
serious revisions since its original
version proposed by charles darwin back
in 1859
still the basic principles of the theory
are the same
and to date the theory of evolution is
the only serious scientific theory that
accurately describes the process of the
evolution of species and the origin of
new creatures
according to some scientists we are now
living in the epoch of the sixth mass
extinction event
they also call it the holocene or
anthropocene extinction
thousands of species have died out in
the past 10 000 years around 900 species
have vanished from the face of the earth
in the past 500 years
today about 40 of amphibian species and
25 percent of mammal species are under
the threat of extinction and it looks
like one of the chief reasons for this
is human activity
the history of life on earth is still
being recorded
the primordial struggle for survival is
going on even at this moment
and we cannot say with any certainty
what our planet will look like in
hundreds of millions of years perhaps
its surface will be covered with
lifeless deserts and humans will refer
to another planet as their home
the universe is full of other worlds
which are quite out of bounds right now
but nevertheless so attractive to humans
who have always been keen on seeing
beyond the horizon
so far we have made only the first timid
steps in exploring the boundless
universe
and there are all sorts of countless
secrets waiting for us up ahead
you